thought-provoking new book says to be
human is to suffer but it's that pain
which also brings healing and wisdom the
offer more beautiful than before her
suffering transform us is rabbi Steve
leader he examines how we learn from
painful events in our lives leader
teaches those lessons while counseling
his huge congregation as senior rabbi at
the Wilshire Boulevard temple it is the
oldest synagogue in Southern California
rabbi leader is with us this morning
good morning good morning suffering is
is instructive suffering is good for us
suffering leads us to what in a way I
think we're all only truly whole after
we've been broken somehow because
there's a depth of empathy and wisdom
and kindness that only comes from having
suffered some form of physical or
emotional pain you know success doesn't
teach us very much it only encourages us
to keep doing the same it's only really
pain that forces us to change it gets us
to a place that we might not otherwise
have gotten there is no other way to get
to that place you say everybody at some
point is going to walk through hell in
their lives you believe just don't come
out empty and exactly we all walk
through hell we are there are many kinds
of hell cancer death a kid in trouble
addiction divorce depression anxiety
there are many forms of health but you
don't have to come out of hell empty
hand you even speak rabbi about you had
to go through suffering yourself to you
said you really didn't even understand
it until you were brought to your knees
by a very painful accident and had
severe back problems the change you've
made you nicer you said it's true it's
absolutely true if I think that rabbis
were always nice well nice earth okay I
don't think I was a bad guy before but
definitely changed the way in which I
relate to people when they come to me
name it I've become a better listener I
have become a kinder person more
apathetic more empathetic and more
authentic when responding to their fears
and anxieties and it talked to you about
taking care of yourself as well and not
just your congregation you went back to
the temple and you were there for the
services even when your wife wanted you
at home
on the mend right yeah one thing I was
struck by in the book you said the
hardest vocabulary words in the English
language are I'm sorry please forgive me
apology accepted yes that say about our
state as a nation right now when we
can't say those three phrases well even
more than I'm sorry
you know there's a piece in this book
called hurt and run which talks about
three words even more difficult for
human beings to say than I'm sorry and
those three words are I was wrong that
is a much higher degree of ownership of
culpability of responsibility for our
mistakes I was wrong
can change everything it takes the sting
out it it makes healing and
Reconciliation possible but to say I was
wrong requires a degree of humility that
few people achieve without having
suffered some kind of debilitating
emotional or physical pain you also say
that no one indoors pain better alone
correct so many times we try to suck it
up buck it up and you said that's the
wrong thing to do that's correct it's
usually that gold alone attitude that
gets us into trouble in the first place
there's another essay in the book called
the prisoner cannot free himself none of
us can free ourselves we have to be
either in enough pain and therefore
humble enough or needy enough to reach
out and if you reach out to people you
will be pleasantly surprised they will
help you want that suffering they do
want to help and of course you will be
disappointed by some but mostly
pleasantly surprised by others you know
you have a great line that people who
really matter don't mind and the people
who mind don't really matter that's
right when you are suffering and you
reach out the people who really matter
don't mind you reaching out and the
people who mind they really don't matter
suffering does strip away a lot of
nonsense from our lives you also say
don't always be comfortable right yes I
think if we're too comfortable it means
we're doing something wrong right it
also means if we're comfortable to a
certain degree it means we're also
turning a blind eye to the suffering of
others there's a piece in the book from
my diary when I visited Uganda
and you know to be blind to that
suffering in order to remain comfortable
oneself is frankly to be a narcissistic
cold human being we have to be open to
the suffering of others we need each
other in this book is about helping each
other it's an easy read you've got a
congregation at ten thousand people so
ten thousands a lot of needs thank you
later thank you really beautiful book
it's called more beautiful than before
it's available wherever you like to buy
your books